Madrid a sprawling metropolis with
architecture representing several
centuries a drive down the main ground
via Boulevard gives visitors an
impression of the energetic vibe of the
Spanish capital located directly in the
centre of town the plus of my yours
Madrid's main square
it's a popular gathering place filled
with cafés public relations manager
Marcela de la pena was born and raised
here in her spare time she writes a blog
giving tourists insider tips if I only
had a day I would definitely suggest a
bit of culture one of a visit to one of
the three major museum we have in Madrid
like the Prado the Reina Sofia or the
Titian I would also suggest shopping
because apart from the big and
well-known Spanish brands that everybody
knows we also have in Islamic a district
really nice shops for Spanish brands and
the third thing I would suggest the
Mercado Cimmerian the mercado de san
miguel is located just a few meters away
from the plaza my AR the structure dates
back to 1916 unlike other Spanish
markets this is not a place to do
ordinary grocery shopping but rather a
venue to enjoy an array of Spanish
delicacies
the decimal is very touristic as you can
see there are a lot of people at every
hour of the day it was an old market
that they have renovated and the good
thing is that you have like all the good
choices of Spanish gastronomy especially
the America ham
following Marcela's second tip we head
to the shopping district of Salamanca
this is Madrid's most exclusive suburb
with narrow tree-lined streets and small
boutiques which offer unique items that
are hard to find anywhere else
Marcela's blog also outlines where
tourists can go if they are in search of
authentic Spanish design
[Music]
Madrid is very good for shopping a must
is Salamanca neighborhood for that and
you will find like very exclusive
boutiques like this one where they sell
very fashion leather bags with Spanish
leather of course for tourists
interested in taking in some culture the
Prado Museum or the thyssen-bornemisza
private collection or the Reina Sofia
must be put on the list of places to go
the Reina Sofia museum opened in 1992
and houses contemporary art including an
icon of the 20th century Pablo Picasso's
Guernica depicting the 1937 bombing of
the town in the Basque Country we have a
great collection of certain Spanish
artists like the me like Miro like
congressman hunter and of course Picasso
a collection that deals with artistic
issues but also deals with political
with social issues collection that is
historical is our immediate past but
Israel it also has to do with the
present
for sports fans a tour of the Bernabeu
stadium is also a must this is home to
the champion soccer team Real Madrid the
stevia museum houses all of the team's
trophies including the 12 European Cups
won over the years
the best way to round off a day of
sightseeing in Madrid is by heading back
to the city centre to the well-known
street of kebab aha this is where
numerous tapas bars are located the
Spanish typically eat tapas is a snack
between meals and they are always served
with a drink
[Music]
the word happens nowadays is very common
but not many people know that the origin
of the word is because in the old times
when you use order a drink they would
serve it with a cover like this which
would be a bit of cheese or ham nowadays
when you ask for tapas
they can serve you something like this
we have a little bit of cheese
we have chorizo and we have breadsticks
Madrid might have a big city feel to it
but life here moves at a slow leisurely
pace that is also what tourists can
enjoy when visiting this city
you